breaking news now the irish prime
minister
is to issue a formal apology after a
report published in the last few minutes
detailed the sheer scale of abuse that
took place at mother and baby homes in
ireland
over a 75-year period the five-year
investigation was prompted by the
discovery
of a mass grave of babies and children
in county galway
our island correspondent stephen murphy
joins me
now this is a long awaited long overdue
report
many argue um talk us through some of
its findings soon
yeah sure it's a report as you mentioned
that has literally just been published
in the last few minutes on the irish
government website
it's around three thousand pages long so
we're just skimming through it at the
moment but i mean
uh some of the findings and some of the
language contained in this report is
pretty damning stuff it's described in
ireland
it calls a cold harsh environment for
many but particularly
cold and harsh for women all women in
ireland
suffered serious discrimination and
women who gave birth outside marriage
were subject to what it calls
particularly harsh treatment
many of these women went into the 18
institutions covered
by this report over many decades they
were forced under
pressure from family societal factors
and of course the influence of the
catholic church
to give birth to babies within these
so-called mother and baby homes they
were then
separated from those children and those
children were often given out for
adoption
or fostering elsewhere sometimes as far
away as the united states
many of those children never saw their
families never saw their biological
parents again the report goes on to say
however that there's no evidence that
women were forced to enter these homes
by the church or state authorities and i
know for a fact that many
of the survivors will vehemently dispute
that we have heard stories of the last
day or two
of um the local parish priests coming to
a home in the 1940s or the 1950s
and telling the family that the daughter
of the family a young
pregnant but unmarried woman was causing
a scandal
one described how his mother had been
bicycled on the crossbars of a bike at
seven months pregnant uh 10 to 12 miles
to enter one of these homes and then the
baby
once it was born was taken away from her
never to be seen again that's what
you're dealing with
uh in this report now i think the
headline figure is the death toll
uh the report confirms that 9 000 irish
children died in these homes and
during the period study that at times
that was twice
the national average mortality rate as
you mentioned there this
commission was set up after uh
groundbreaking work done by the
historian catherine corliss at the site
of a home in tomb in county galway in
the west of the country
we caught up with her there a bit
earlier and asked her why so many
children died
i believe that with a bit of hygiene and
with a bit of care
quite a number of babies could be saved
but it seems they were just lumped in
together
a disease was ram went rampant from one
to the other
and um the bottom cause in my for my
research
i can say neglect big time needle actor
not caring
and you can see you can see the lack of
care of when to give them no funeral
no proper barrier so it just it screams
off just
pure neglect
there have been several interim reports
by this commission so we had an inkling
of
what was contained but there's no doubt
the the findings and the language in
this 3000 page report
uh is sure to be shocking to many as the
details emerge over the coming
uh minutes and hours we're just about to
have a press briefing here at government
buildings in dublin
uh from the taoiseach the irish prime
minister me hall martin to hear
more details of the state's response but
it is expected he will issue a state
a formal state apology when the doll the
irish parliament returns
tomorrow but for now there's no doubt
this is a another
grim recap of a dark chapter in modern
irish society